je vous le disais en titre la bretagne
n'en finit pas d'être touchées par les
inondations la nuit dernière de très
fortes pluies ont provoqué la montée des
eaux notamment à quimperlé où le niveau
atteint la côte d'alerté
les habitants aidés par les pompiers ont
commencé à quitter les maisons situées
dans les zones inondées et jacques
chirac ce soir exprime sa profonde
sympathie et solidarité aux bretons
affirmant que la nation les aidera à
surmonter ces nouvelles épreuves
reportages chaque de vous les zodiac ont
repris du service prête à toute
éventualité
ce soir quimperlé est de nouveau sous
les eaux au dernier pointage la laïta
est à 4 mètres 83 près de deux mètres au
dessus de son niveau de débordements les
maisons et les commerces de la basse
ville sont une nouvelle fois inondées et
la lassitude se fait sentir un peu tendu
fatigue etc un ras-le-bol train à ras
bol parce que bon
on récupère de l'eau en amont qui vous
arrive et c'est bon j'ai bien c'est
naturel mais aurait peut-être que
d'autres communes comme le faouët et des
autres maintenant responsabilité à faire
des barrages et inondé leur pays parce
que on va pas sans arrêt récupérer tout
ça
jusqu'à quand ça va durer une fois
encore
chacun cherche à protéger ses biens
comme il le peut de la montée des eaux
des barrages parfois dérisoires sont
érigés dans l'urgence ne part pas ça
suffira si la passion de très franc
les commerçants qui ont réouvert depuis
la dernière crue se méfier alors ils
protègent de nouveau leurs articles et
les places le plus haut possible en
train de sauver les vélos la face qu en
prévision de la montée des eaux
on a peur que ça rentre dans le magasin
de nouveau donc on fait le maximum quoi
une fois ça suffit une fois ça suffit
donc on va au moins sauvé l'essentiel
aucune panique ne touche la population
les habitants qui dès les maisons les
plus menacés les autres s'installa
laitages et attendent la décrue résigné
en espérant que la pluie cesse enfin on
est tous à regarder le ciel attendre que
viendra viendra pas c'est une situation
un petit peu frustrant et difficile
parce qu'il ya beaucoup d'anxiété dans
la population mais comme ça ce soir-là
cru s'est stabilisé à 50 cm au dessous
du niveau atteint le 12 décembre dernier
la météo devrait être plus clémente ce
week-end et favoriser la décrue